c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir la fin officielle de
l'opération barkham le président
français l'a annoncé ce mercredi à
Toulon dans le sud de la France alors
qu'il présentait la nouvelle stratégie
de Paris en matière de défense celle
concernant l'Afrique sera finalisé sous
6 mois les détails dans un instant des
militants écologistes qui manifestent à
Paris contre le projet
icoop le peuple a une chauffée qui doit
acheminer du brut entre l'Ouganda et la
Tanzanie sa construction devrait bientôt
commencer mais les conséquences sur
l'environnement et les populations à son
nombreuses reportages à suivre
et puis les Sénégalais sous le choc leur
star Sadio Mane pourrait être forfait
pour la Coupe du Monde l'international
s'est blessée au tibia à 11 jours du
Mondial nous serons à Dakar dans ce
journal et nous irons également dans son
village où vous verrez qu'il est annulé
Emmanuel Macron était à Toulon dans le
sud de la France ce mercredi il a
présenté la nouvelle stratégie française
en matière de défense il en a profité
pour officialiser la fin de l'opération
barkhane il appelait dès pour des
interventions limitées dans le temps les
détails avec Nadia markloufi
le chef de l'État français est fait son
annonce depuis la base navale de Toulon
nos interventions doivent être mieux
bornés dans le temps et ce dès le début
nous n'avons en effet pas vocation à
rester engagé sans limite de temps dans
des opérations extérieures
c'est aussi pour cette raison que j'ai
décidé en concertation avec nos
partenaires d'officialiser aujourd'hui
la fin de l'opération barkhane une
opération lancée ne vend plutôt à la
demander
la menace terroriste existe aussi au
Burkina Faso Niger Road et en Mauritanie
au total 5100 soldats sont déployés sur
zone plusieurs millions de kilomètres
carrés sont ainsi placé sous
surveillance après des années de
présence et de lutte le constat est
amère l'opération est un échec notamment
en raison de l'instabilité politique au
Tchad au Burkina Faso et au Mali où la
jante au pouvoir travaille main dans la
main avec le groupe paramilitaire Wagner
alors que l'influence russe s'étend la
présence française n'est plus souhaitée
l'annonce de la fin de barkhane est en
revanche sans condition immédiate sur le
dispositif militaire français au Sahel
3000 soldats sont toujours déployés au
Niger au Tchad au Burkina FA Paris se
donne encore 6 mois pour finaliser sa
nouvelle stratégie en Afrique
la réaction à cette annonce du président
français au Tchad pour le ministre
tchadien des Affaires étrangères ce
n'est pas une surprise écoutez-le il
s'exprimait au micro de notre
correspondant Mamadou gitane
il ne se prend pas parce que depuis un
certain temps ce qu'on appelle la
réalité du
dispositif français en Afrique et
particulièrement ça elle de façon
générale et en train de se discuter et
je sais qu'il y a une réflexion
d'ensemble qui était menée pour voir un
peu que les nouvelles
position du dispositif répercussions je
ne sais pas la coopération entre la
France et le plan bilatéral avec hôtel
ou tel pays tel que je sais elle va
continuer et je crois que c'est une
décision française qu'il serait pas bon
de commentaires
la situation sécuritaire dans l'est de
la République démocratique du Congo est
toujours aussi pré
occupe personne ont été tuées et un
centre de santé incendié dans la nuit de
mardi à mercredi une attaque attribuée
au rebelles ADF une milice en provenance
de l'Ouganda voisin un médecin a été
kidnappé la Pharmacie du Centre de Santé
piller lors de cette attaque survenue
dans un village et une dizaine de
kilomètres de la ville de Béni dans le
Nord qui vous
on en vient à ce projet de plus en plus
décrié par les ONG il s'agit du couple
Papeline chauffé le plus long du monde
sa construction va bientôt commencer
pour acheminer du brut entre l'Ouganda
et la Tanzanie mais de nombreuses voix
s'élèvent pour dénoncer des conséquences
désastreuses sur l'environnement et les
populations locales reportage de Julie
Chouteau
la plupart desambules comme des morts
vivants pour symboliser les citoyens en
danger d'autres se réjouissent de
l'hécatombe et de l'argent qu'ils en
tirent avec cette performance ces
militants parisiens dénoncent le projet
est africain du géant pétrolier français
Total énergie l'oléoduc hicoque va
acheminer du pétrole extrait en Ouganda
jusqu'en Tanzanie d'où il pourrait être
exporté via l'océan Indien ça sera un
pipeline de plus de 1400 km un pipeline
chauffé à 50 degrés donc vous imaginez
l'absurdité environnementale et ce
Paypal en fait va passer par des parcs
naturels qui sont protégés donc faut
imaginer que ça va un impact énorme sur
la biodiversité nous on a des libertés
publiques en nous Ganda quand ils se
quand il manifestent ils sont
emprisonnés pendant plusieurs jours donc
nous on a la chance de le faire et donc
on se montre aussi solidaire avec eux en
tant que c'est hyper important pendant
ce temps à l'intérieur de l'Assemblée
nationale le PDG de Total énergie répond
aux questions des députés français
Patrick puyannet conteste le chiffre de
cent mille personnes expropriées et
s'engage à dédommager ce qui doivent
abandonner leur maison et leur terre le
nombre de foyers qui sont concernés par
la nécessité de les reloger et nous
reconstruisons des maisons et de 769
foyers et le nombre de paires de terre
agricoles de personnes concernées par
des terres agricoles que nous devons
effectivement compenser et de 19000 mais
en nous Ganda aussi certaines voix
s'élèvent pour dénoncer les conditions
d'expropriation de ceux qui vivent ou
cultivent sur le tracé du futur oléo duc
comme le principal opposant politique
Bobby wine le mois dernier
il y a des violations flagrantes des
droits de l'homme il faut y être très
attentif
si le président mousse Evenia qui est-ce
alors cela veut dire qu'il y a une
politique de violation des droits de
l'homme ici en Ouganda
a été signé entre la Tanzanie et
l'Ouganda en 2020 total énergie doit le
construire en collaboration avec une
compagnie pétrolière chinoise date
prévue de mise en service 2025
la répression au Tchad les deux
principaux leaders d'opposition succès
massera et maxa luanga ont annoncé que
leur mouvement avait demandé à la Cour
pénale internationale de La Haye
d'enquêter sur des crimes contre
l'humanité ils affirment de voir se
cacher par crainte de représailles trois
semaines après une manifestation
réprimée dans le sang ils ont tous tout
deux pardon affirmés que la répression
se poursuivait par des arrestations
déportation et des exécutions
extrajudiciaires
en bref la reprise progressive des vols
de la compagnie aérienne kenyane Airways
à l'aéroport de nairobie c'est pilote
ont mis fin à une greffe qui avait
paralysé des centaines de vols durant 4
jours mardi un tribunal avait ordonné la
reprise du travail
aujourd'hui les Sénégalais ont eu la
sensation que le ciel leur tombait sur
la tête Sadio Mané la star du football
pourrait être forfait pour la Coupe du
Monde il s'est blessé à 11 jours du
début de la compétition touché au tibia
lors d'un match avec le Bayern pour en
parler nous retrouvons tout de suite à
Dakar notre correspondant à Liman Dao
elimann bonsoir les Sénégalais sont très
inquiets
oui ils sont très très inquiets
inquiétudes manifestées depuis ce mardi
ils sont toujours très nombreux à
regarder les matchs de Sadio Mane avec
le Bayern Munich lors du choc opposant
le Bayern ouvert à la dizaine minute de
jeu Sadio Mané assis sur la pelouse se
plaignait de douleur au niveau du genou
avant que ce matin le journal L'Équipe
annonce à la surprise générale qu'il
sera forfait pour la Coupe du Monde des
Sénégalais n'ont pas voulu y croire
jusqu'à une information beaucoup plus
rassurante du Bayern Munich indiquant
juste qu'il sera absent pour le match du
week-end prochain en Bundesliga de
championnat allemand de football
opposant de Bayern à Schalke 04 et plus
tard
le Bayern Munich le staff médical qui
est en train en contact avec le staff de
l'équipe nationale du Sénégal de
football c'est le sujet en tout cas ce
qui est sur toutes les lèvres depuis ce
matin les télévisions sont même mis en
édition spéciale et le président de la
République en Macky Sall a souhaité sur
Twitter en prendre pour à la star de
l'équipe nationale du Sénégal de
football est-ce qu'il est Sénégalais
sont autant préoccupés par l'état de
santé de Sadio Mane c'est parce que
c'est déjà la star de l'équipe nationale
le joueur le plus dangereux
offensivement on va dire de cette équipe
nationale le joueur qui a qualifié le
Sénégal à la Coupe du monde mais c'est
également parce que Sadio Mané au-delà
du terrain est une idole absolue grâce
notamment aux réalisations faites dans
son village à bambali au sud du Sénégal
nous nous sommes rendus à la base je
vous propose de suivre ce reportage fait
à bambali le village de Sadio Mane
c'est sur ce terrain de bambali que
Sadio Mané a fait ses premières passes
aujourd'hui des dizaines de jeunes y
jouent chaque jour tous ces espèrent
devenir footballeurs professionnels en
ce moment 15 ans fait partie des grands
talents du village
j'aimerais devenir un grand joueur de
foot pour surtout aider ma famille et
mon village comme le fait Sadio Mane
inspire autant sur le terrain qu'un d'or
c'est nombreuses réalisations à bambali
lui ont permis de remporter le trophée
secrétès décerné par le magazine France
Football au lycée qui accueille 800
élèves une antenne 4G pour mieux
connecter bambali au reste du monde et
surtout un centre de santé précieux qui
réduit la fracture sanitaire dans cette
localité reculée du Sud du Sénégal
il a gagné sa vie il est né ici grandeur
ici il n'a pas oublié son village après
avoir gagné des milliards et la
directement penser son village et son
village en problème il a construit la
même c'est un acte a remercié avant on
était obligé de faire 20 km pour se
soigner maintenant grâce à Sadio on a un
hôpital
à la maison familiale les matchs de
Sadio Mane avec son peuple du Bayern
Munich sont suivis religieusement ici la
générosité de l'attaquant sénégalais ne
surprend pas
j'ai grandi avec Sadio Mané et il a
toujours été un homme avec un grand cœur
il a toujours voulu réussir dans la vie
pour aider ces semblables
c'est une personne exceptionnelle
face au Pays-Bas au-delà de bambali
c'est toute une nation qui espère voir
Sadio Mané parmi les protagonistes du
plus grand rendez-vous de la planète
football
voilà on comprend pourquoi Sadio Mané
était aussi adulée au même en dehors de
200 villages merci beaucoup à Liman Daho
on suivra évidemment le rétablissement
qu'on espère de Sadio Mané dans le
journal de l'Afrique merci beaucoup
c'est la fin de cette édition restez
avec nous l'info continue sur France 24
[Musique]